well there's a lot of interest this
morning in Florida where voters cast a
record number of early ballots they'll
decide high-profile races for governor
and the Senate one of the newest polls
shows the Democratic candidates with 7
point leads Manuel Bojorquez is at a
polling place in Tallahassee the state
capital men well good morning good
morning there was a line of voters here
waiting to get in now they are in and
casting their ballots now the Democrats
have a slight edge according to the
polls going into Election Day but the
races here remained very competitive the
big ticket item here is the race for
governor between the current mayor of
this town Tallahassee the Democrat
Andrew Gilliam and former Republican
congressman Ron De Santis and Gilliam
just pulled ahead by 7 points according
to a new poll if elected he would become
the first african-american governor in
state history De Santis has the support
of President Trump who carried the state
in the 2016 presidential election both
of cash Gilliam is too extreme for
Florida we asked Gilliam whether he
feels the race is a referendum on the
president I think mr. DeSantis is making
this a referendum on mr. Trump it's hard
to tell the difference between the two
of them in these final days of the race
Gilliam will take us in a direction that
people like Bernie Sanders and all these
people want to go in it's not going to
lead to success for our state meanwhile
three term Democratic Senator Bill
Nelson is trying to fend off a challenge
from current Florida Governor Rick Scott
to win back the Senate Democrats need to
hold on to Nelson seat and recent polls
show Nelson has a 13-point advantage
with independent voters Norah
all right man well thank you